unjustified and unexplained was how the
head of nato described russia's buildup
of troops on its border with ukraine
after a meeting with ukraine's foreign
minister in brussels
russia must end this military buildup
in and around ukraine stop its
provocations
and de-escalate immediately
russia has deployed naval ships heavy
armor and tens of thousands of troops
in recent weeks violence has risen
between russian-backed separatists
and ukrainian forces in ukraine's east
ukraine's foreign minister said nato
must respond
to what he called a threat of war by
gathering today
we try to avoid the mistake that was
made in 2014
when russia was ready to act swiftly
and pursue its military goals in crimea
and donbass while our western partners
were
considering their reactions to what was
happening
on the ground russia will not be able to
catch
anyone by surprise anymore kuleba also
discussed the situation with the u.s
secretary of state
who's on a three-day visit to brussels
the u.s will station an extra 500 troops
in germany
we're seeing unfortunately russia
take a very provocative action when it
comes to ukraine we're now seeing
the largest concentration of russian
forces
on ukraine's borders since 2014.
kremlin officials say the troops are on
a training exercise
and that ukraine has been acting
provocatively
some analysts say putin is less
interested in conflict
than in challenging washington what we
have seen over the last few months is a
breakdown
of the u.s russian relation since the
biden administration
uh took uh uh power and and i think
putin is basically replying to that
and he's testing uh the biden
administration to see
how far are they willing to go how hot
turf are they really
are on on russia kiev wants nato to
fast-track its request for membership of
the alliance
ukraine's president says such a move
would help end the conflict with russia
by sending a clear message to moscow the
ukraine's sovereignty
could not be threatened natasha butler
al jazeera
paris